gentlemen congratulations on the movie
thank you thank you uh is it nice to
finally be able to talk specifics and
like actually get into it instead of
like two years of being guarded with
your answers yeah I mean we're still a
guy with a few things but yeah we can
get a little more specific about what
people have seen two years have guarded
with uh I don't know about that but uh
anyway crack on um I just have to ask
you real quick if you don't mind so you
have voiced Green Lantern you're now
Hawkman um who is the next character
you're playing in the DC Universe
uh hogman hogman and Hawkman hopefully
if this uh this train keeps moving one
of the things that I was really
surprised with the movie in a good way
was
um how violent it is um like Black Adam
really kills a ton of people and I
wasn't sure Dwayne was gonna do it
um but like that's the character and he
really puts it on screen yeah can you
sort of talk about that asp expect that
this is not a black atom that's pulling
any punches yeah
this is raw it's raw and Hearty and yes
the you know Black Adam does kill openly
a lot of bad guys you know I think it's
it's important to know he's killing bad
guys um for the sake of the people that
he's protecting and you know for for his
moral compass but
um along with that it really is a
backdrop to the real conversation that
we're having in terms of what is good
and evil what is right and wrong and to
what extinct do you go to what lengths
do you reach uh to accomplish what you
believe is actual Justice right what is
the definition of True Justice when it
means different things to all people so
for Black Adam especially as he comes up
against the JSA and they both have two
very different foundations for justice
it becomes that personal individual and
at the same time cultural conversation
about
what belief system
is the right choice to go with and you
know there's there's real hard and real
Dynamic sort of
um
I want to say wait to what we're doing
here but we have the explosions the
great Powers we put that on full display
in the most maximum way ever but it's
all anchored to something that is real
and full of substance when you walk away
from the theater with some real things
to talk about I'll ask you a a question
um you've worked on so many different
projects at so many different levels
what was the thing that maybe surprised
you the most about making Black Adam and
how it compared to some of the other
projects you've worked on well it's just
the scope of this story
the vastness was very operatic it's huge
it's uh the mythology of comic book
World which is you know
far-reaching this movie has what let me
think about this a little bit of action
um
you know just a little bit but um there
is some some a big battle sequence
between you and Black Adam in an
apartment that as I was watching I was
really mesmerized by how they filmed it
and what was going on I don't want to
reveal anything but can you sort of talk
about what it takes to film a sequence
like that and what it's like to fight
you know the rock well it takes months
of preparation but it takes a fantastic
stunt team stunt coordinator but all
that is brought together by the vision
of DP and the direction and further
vision of an amazing director that you
know like we had Larry share who's our
DP we have Jean will call it Sarah our
director who really you know they
composed sort of cinematic ballet when
it came to these things it's not just
about fighting and being brutal it's
about how do you how do you exercise the
most beautiful way to actually put this
on display and they knew they were
reaching for and not even reaching but
actually holding on to a different way
to show
what a fight sequence looks like what
superpowers look like you know and this
is not something I feel like we've seen
in the DCU or even in any superhero
Universe we've seen thus far that's what
I love about it is we get to introduce
and present a new way to experience and
see what you know a real battle looks
like so they were creating art in the
moment and that is exactly what you see
you see beautiful art on the page on
that note I already have to wrap I'm
just going to say I know it's going to
be a big hit congratulations thank you
for your time thank you